teachers unions and school boards across
the country have been focused on mask
mandates and remote learning for a big
chunk of the last year shocking new
study reveals just how bad things have
really gotten for your kids the report
shows that student test scores across
the country have fallen for the first
time in the nation's history 13 year
olds are less proficient in math and
reading than they were almost a decade
ago that's according to data collected
just before the start of the pandemic
jesse you've got school age kiddos
this was before the pandemic things were
getting bad how much worse has it been
for your kids over the last year and a
half well they're okay because they're
in catholic schools and the catholics
don't play they were in person it's true
learning and reading so we're we're
grateful for that but
in slavery the ruling class would not
allow black americans to read they
didn't want them to have an education
why because knowledge is power and if
someone doesn't have that knowledge and
power it's easier to dominate you and
that thinking is still prevalent today
the ruling class in this country and all
over the world they don't want this
generation that educated they want them
educated enough so they can do menial
jobs and kind of entry level management
but they don't want them intelligent so
they start asking questions like where
are all the hundreds of billions of
dollars that are going into these public
school systems that keep failing why
don't they teach economics in school why
do they keep failing students and then
graduating them to the next class
and you wonder why people can't do math
and then you realize that they're
teaching you that math is racist so
there are powerful people in this
country that don't care about education
they want indoctrination they want
people mad at the other race and they
want them kind of divided so they're
distracted and dumb so they're not
seeing what the ruling class is doing
raiding the treasury opening the borders
and sending all the jobs to china
jessica that feels very brave new world
it's very aldous huxley
from jesse
i always try to think before the show
like what will jessie say
bracelet doesn't take too long don't you
have downloads don't thank you
i don't know
no definitely not and
obviously i vehemently disagree with the
comparison to what slave owners were
doing and trying to keep people enslaved
and working on plantations versus what
educators and quote ruling class folks
are doing and i have think about it for
a second because you're not allowing
people to do charter schools and now
they're saying you don't want parents to
have a stake in their child's education
if you
interrupt that little power structure
that we have set up right now
that unleashes the beast you know we've
been talking about how that may be one
of the big things in this virginia
governor's race it is absolutely and
there was the comment that terry
mcauliffe made during the debate about
this it's certainly an important issue i
just we have a ton of charter schools in
this country and democrats believe that
we also need to improve the public
schools so that everyone can have an
opportunity to have a great education
there a lot of democrats who are also
pro-charter school i would remind you if
you even look at michelle rhee's work
obviously that's a great example of that
there are definitely failings of the
public school system the impact of not
only zoom school but the mental health
strain of the last 18 months on young
people i'm sure is going to continue to
factor into these testing results and
living here i've been following closely
obviously with eric adams who
will be our mayor
come election day here in new york city
has been saying and mayor de blasio
talked about eliminating our gifted and
talented programs and eric adams came
out and said hey i don't think you can
do that and b i would never do that and
i think that keeping the standards makes
such a difference especially in helping
along the kids who are succeeding in
these systems and also identifying the
kids who may need a little bit of extra
help and i hope that obviously those
programs stay in that we see more of
that yeah and katie she mentioned
jessica talks about the mental health
issues and i was reading today about
this one ceo of a children's hospital in
connecticut said that they are so
overwhelmed
with beds for children who need
inpatient psychiatric care because of
what they've been through the last year
and a half and that's certainly not
going to reflect well educationally
either
i think for a lot of parents and and
logically thinking people
this is especially infuriating because
if you look at the consequences and all
of the data whether it's mental health
or test scores this was obvious of in
summer of 2020. you had uh senator rand
paul have an exchange with dr fauci in
may of 2020 saying hey we really need
schools to be open in the fall because
there will be consequences especially
for minority students if we don't do
that whether it's mental health or their
education falling behind and they're
never going to be able to make it up
when you look at these numbers it's like
how are these kids ever going to be able
to get that time back how are they ever
going to catch up especially when you
have unions who repeatedly over the past
year whenever there was a compromise
made for them to get back to the
classroom they threw up another
roadblock we want more money we want
more vaccines we want this we want that
and then parents who dared to say
well we would really like our schools to
be open and we think some of these
covered restrictions are pretty
ridiculous considering that you guys
were vaccinated and put in front of the
line and then they were doxxed and then
they were shut out of school board
meetings and then when parents found out
what they were actually teaching their
children because of the zoom call the
zoom learning they were then called
racist and bigoted and so you know one
silver lining of this may be that there
is a new school choice revolution that
is happening you had a school board
member today in loudoun county um resign
as a result of parent parental
involvement and so again just generally
you can apply the standard of
did we see this coming a year ago we did
and because everybody listened to
anthony fauci this is the consequence
that was warned about well and a lot of
other countries have handled this
differently the masking the kids in
school out of school but what we found
out here is that the kids who were
already trailing behind are the ones who
have slipped even further because of
this right i think there's got to be a
creative way to attack the inner city
schools because money's pouring in but
it's not being used in an effective way
it's not like they're being starved out
i will say from what i judge my son went
to private school my two daughters went
to public school one thing was
consistent ton of homework i thought it
was much more homework they they worked
and everybody i talked to i can't
believe how much homework these kids
have i don't think they had it easy and
i don't i have to see where these
targeted scores are and why they're not
producing results but i think you have
uh this there's a what you're saying is
correct too is that we're putting a lot
of money into these schools it's not
necessarily democrat or republican
jessica that talks about charter schools
it's just great competition
give an opportunity for these charter
schools to compete with the public
schools the public schools will get
better the charter schools will make the
public schools better if a competition
happens and in virginia it changes
leaders changes parties and if we could
find a way to see if you could take your
money your public school money and you
put it towards the private school man
game on in terms of effectiveness
that is called standings that is that is
well terry mcauliffe just said to your
point of the charter schools getting
public money from parents that he would
not allow that as governor democrat and
there is a case coming at the supreme
court in a couple of months that is
going to be about money moving with kids
and whether it can be used in private
schools so think about that as well
though the result will be better schools
all around